hey y'all it's endercouch here and in
this hygienist video we'll be continuing
my series on
r shiny and we're going to focus on
reactive
variables so in my first video i went
over
you know the filtering functions which
add some reactiveness
and some dynamicness to your dashboards
but um i was basically
hard-coding most of this stuff you know
we're using um very consistent data sets
and uh in real life you're probably
gonna have you know some different
variables that are changing
whenever you're using the dashboard so i
figured i would make a video on
reactive variables or things that
basically will be changing
while you use the dashboard i'm going to
show you this first bare bones dashboard
where it's the reactive variables
dashboard
and it shows a generic pairwise plot
that's kind of useful for exploratory
analysis
of the iris data set
so one of the things that we want to
kind of think about is you know if we
have a dashboard maybe for edas
we would want someone to basically like
upload a data set and
basically have that plot come out oops
that's a little
scraper schedule that i have at 12 um
but we would probably want to like
upload a file and then that file would
go into
um this little plot right here
um and what we know is that with gg duo
or the gt ally package
it's just a simple function to call but
we need to replace this data set with
a data set that we want to basically
choose okay
so one of the things that we would think
about probably is like oh
we'll just do like a read dot you know
csv filename.csv and you know we'll just
select the file name and it'll read it
in
but it's not that simple unfortunately
what we need to realize though is that
um our shiny is expecting kind of like
a consistent variable unless if we
specify that
it's actually changing so in this case
what we'd probably want to do is
actually add like a file like an upload
file button
so we can actually do that um by using
the file
input and we'll call this the v
uh we'll call it v file input and our
label
will be say like upload file
uh we can run that it'll show you this
little thing right here where you can
browse and select the file
in this case i actually have the iris
data set right here so you just upload
it right there
and it's pretty slick with a nice little
ui
that being said um we have this v file
input and
i think we could try to do a input
e file input and see if it actually
works
right so as you can see we already have
an error
um but if we upload it it'll actually
upload this stuff
but we can see that there's a lot of
weird stuff going on
because it's actually in uh it's
actually um using this file input
as essentially this metadata for what
we're trying to upload
right so we're not seeing the actual
species or the simple links we're kind
of seeing
the the name of the file the size the
type and the data path
it's not something we really want to
plot out um instead what we actually
have to do is kind of like parse
the actual file data um and this will
actually be helpful because we're
actually going to create a reactive
variable
in this case we're going to create a
reactive variable in the server
because it'll be in our back end so what
i'll call it is file data
um and then what we can do is use the
reactive function
and in this case we'll have our file
it'll be our input
v file v file input
and what we can kind of do is also add a
little um
um a little uh helper so we'll say like
if
uh it's not missing
file right then we can just kind of read
the file um
in this case since we're passing in the
file um the file input so when we select
it
what we want to pass is the actual file
uh the data path
because when you're actually using the
file input
it's basically passing in metal metadata
and then you want to pass that metadata
into
some type of reading function in this
case it's called a data
path and now what we can actually do
is pass this in right here
right but if we actually see
uh it's going to cause us a little error
right so it's saying argument of length
zero and one thing that we have to
realize when we're using these reactive
functions
is we always have to kind of wrap it as
a function so we're basically calling
the file data function
and it's using that file so we can go
right there
um we can go over here and it'll show us
the iris data set
um being plotted up now you might be
wondering
um if we actually run this app again uh
we get this weird little error message
so what we can actually do is
we can um
uh we can also have like a request we
can do a requirement
and that should basically um
do it for right there um
over there see there's no um error it's
just a blank box
when we upload it it'll pop
up so that's a way where we can make a
little bit cleaner um
and that way uh it won't cause us little
errors uh when we open and show
the user the actual dashboard cool
so right there um that's basically what
we really want to kind of focus on is
when we have reactive variables such as
like a variable that's going to be
changing
it's not going to be implicit in the
actual uh app
we always want to make it basically
reactive and then when we use a reactive
variable we also have to call it as a
function
and then we can also use this request
function with it
uh to basically kind of handle all the
errors that we want to
parse out okay so when i'm looking at
this
on one thing that we kind of want to do
is what if we
want to actually like interact with file
with like filtering right
um and that would be pretty useful
especially if we're gonna do like maybe
like a simple modeling thing
so let's actually start doing that so
one thing that we can do is basically
say like let's just assume that we want
to like
create some type of you know logistic
regression
model or some linear model let's just do
a linear model
and we'll just say that um you know when
we upload a file
um when we upload a file
right with the irs data set uh
we can do a basic eda and then we can
say oh well let's predict like simple
links right with this file
since we have our little um explain our
brief eda
chart so let's actually do that with
a basic um selector
so this selector will basically cause um
whatever
it'll basically specify what we want to
predict
in this case what we would want to do is
probably create a select
input but with our select inputs and
having a reactive
variable since our select input is going
to be dependent
on what file we upload we're actually
going to use a little trick
and call it the ui oops ui
output oops or what's called um
yeah ui output by this way ui uh
ui output and we're just going to call
this like the target
variable and what a ui output is
is basically kind of like a uh
a helper um a helper function for
basically
creating any type of ui
right so if we have a ui you also have
to have a
output for the ui so we'll just say um
output we call this what
target var target variable
and we'll just do a render ui
and in this case what we can do is we
can still request our file data
and we can do our select input
so our select input again if we remember
from our previous video is like the
little drop down
so we can kind of select a column that
we want to choose as our
um thing that we want to predict um in
this case we're going to call it v
target
and then we'll say target
uh oops variable
and our choices will be the column names
or file data right
so basically we're saying like once you
upload a file we can start using it
um and then we can say like our choices
or what we want to predict will be the
features or columns from that
data uh that data framework our excel
file
so let's do that we uploaded a file
and now we can see our target variable
pops up right here
obviously it's not going to do anything
because we haven't done anything yet
with it
but it is still extremely uh kind of
cool right
um took about one minute to put into and
uh we can start
you know uh thinking about what we want
to do with it
um and obviously with a simple example
we would probably want to create
a you know model that would basically uh
predict the c
point so when we're trying to do that
what we can do basically is we can think
about uh how we're going to do it which
will be a simple like
lm target uh target
bar our data will equal to our
file data
right so let's actually do that um in
this case you know
since we have a linear model we don't
really we might want to do it for like
inference or something like that
so what i can type in is just create a
simple
like a model diagnostic spot right so
it's kind of something where you would
do it like in excel
um with like the data analysis run the
lm
view the coefficients and you know maybe
analyze the residuals but
let's do a model
model bot
we'll do a model plot and then we'll say
sorry render
what we can put this thing basic in
there
our target variable and we'll just use
the like broom
package to tidy it
and then um oops and then what we can do
is just kind of plot out the coefficient
so
x equals like error y equals estimate uh
color maybe we'll just say because p dot
value is less than equal to
05 and then maybe do a segment
that equals term y n equals zero
energy and point
and i'm just gonna do a little
formatting just because i know like you
know
i'm basically trying to plot out each
coefficient's name
and the variable the uh the co efficient
value
color it whether it's statistically
significant or not
as a basic lollipop um so i've done a
decent amount of
lollipops so i'll just do hs equals one
and then i'll say labs title is equal to
title is like
o efficient
uh coefficients right
so let's actually try this out
uh oh actually i need a
i need to render this plot out so i'll
put this
um right there what output
and we'll do a model output let's see if
it works
iris
and you can see how target variable is
not found
because when we're specifying um
uh when we're specifying this target
variable it's kind of pasting it as an
actual string
and what that caught what that means
basically is that we need to basically
paste it as a formula
so what we can do is uh oh
i'll just show you input uh
target bar actually i'll just show you
uh input b target sorry about that
because
the target bar is actually the ui but
the v target is that
um i can show you that it'll still cause
an error
maybe it won't yeah it'll still call it
because it's saying like variable links
defer
found force equal that length even if we
change it it's like pedaling
it's still not going to do it um because
what we want to do
is paste it as a formula so input v
our target
and do that and then what we can do is
as
formula
has that formula okay
right so if we do that right the formula
we still have that error but let's see
if x doesn't
and we can see how it runs the model
um we can kind of change it you can see
how it's changing
uh obviously if you do species is going
to cause an error um so maybe if
i wanted to make a little bit cleaner
and maybe focus just on regression
problems we would say like
select if is that numeric so let me
actually do that
right here file data
choices file data
select if is not numeric
cool
all right so let's run that he can
put this in
oops what is it what's going on here
selective is that numeric choices
file data
uh let's see your call names
i want to make sure if i
iris select
if is dot numeric oh
maybe that'll work let's see if that'll
actually work
there we go so i must have just spelled
something wrong but we can see how we
can change the target variable
and it still works cool but
um if you think about it you know we
don't really want to render this
this we don't want to train this model
every time we change the variable you
know we might want to do some
you know analysis first for the uh um
um you know we might want to add some
type of functionality where
uh we want to like look at specific
variables maybe run some t-tests
um do some hypothesis testing um either
and then start recreating our models
maybe do a little bit bigger edas so
one of the things that we kind of want
to think about is that hey it'd be kind
of useful
right if we had like a button to
basically execute the model once we kind
of figure out what we want to do
okay again that's pretty straightforward
um because r has the uh um what's the
the action the action button so we can
do that
action button our input id will be like
v button and we'll just call this run
model yep
and now what we can do is think about
when we want to run the model
and since our this button is essentially
a reactive variable
where when we press it it will cause an
action
right it's called an actual event button
or event reactive function
so what we can think about is let's
actually create our like
output like model
uh we'll call like model uh run
it's not an output since it's the same
thing as a reactive function and
realistically i should probably put it
right there um and we can say uh
event reactive
okay and then with our input with our
event reactive we kind of have to pass
in our button that we want to specify
the
um that'll be kind of watching for the
event so for the event reactive you know
we could have tons of buttons
we just need to specify the button that
we want to use in this case it'll be
just
input v button
okay um add a comma and now we have this
and now when we want to run the model we
can actually
pass this in
to their model run
and now if you think about it since this
model run is essentially the same thing
as this file data
they're both data frames um that are
just going to be running on a specific
action or event
so with file data we're going to
generate a data frame once you upload a
file
the model run will actually be dependent
on the file data but when we press the
button
it'll run a linear model on whatever
target variable we sent it
from our filters so what we can do now
is we can kind of work just use the
model run and run
that you know so once we
once we push the execute the model then
we'll generate
a a model run or a model
a linear model with its tidied
coefficients and then we can pass that
in
uh to our model plot
okay so let's look at the iris
and then what we can do is you know
pedal length run the model and we have
it
another thing that we could actually
think about is that hey
well since we have this v target maybe
we should make this a little bit more
reactive so we actually know what you
know we're talking about
um so we can say coefficients uh
uh or uh predicting
and we could say like uh
input target and we'll just say well
subtitle will say using
a linear linear model
and let's actually do that okay
we have our iris it's uploading
we'll predict at a length we'll run the
model
coefficients for predicting paddle
length using a linear model
and then right there you know we have
this basic thing where um we're creating
you know just a you know an interactive
linear model thing uh we can change it
obviously
to like sepal length and then run that
um stuff like that so as you can see
right it it is kind of a little weird
where if we change the target variable
and we don't run it
um we might have to execute it but again
um it's probably something where i you
kind of think about like okay maybe the
select input will
change um with the render plot
um so that might cause some issues but
again you know it's something where you
kind of can work around or build
something
of a higher like uh
you know you could build a little bit
more logic and more infrastructure
around it
okay so one of the things that we kind
of have to think about is okay so let's
say that we ran
we have this dashboard um you know we
give it to some like maybe like a
student who wants to kind of just like
okay i don't want to do any coding
someone runs one of your models you know
you're like an econ student or something
um we want to look at my coefficients
look at the p values and you know just
save them
write a report you know or dive deeper
or send it to like a colleague or
something like that
um so that type of thing right there
is something we probably want to just
like download the results of the model
um and just like email it to someone
right or i don't know like send it on
teams
so what we can do is we can actually
create a download button
right so let's do a download button
and right there we have a download
button we'll call it v
download and we'll say download
model uh oh it's download summary
right what is it download center summary
and one thing that's kind of odd
about um exporting models i'm exporting
as they download
on the download button is that
you actually have to use this kind of
like down handler function
um and i think it's a little bit odd uh
to be honest but
it's something where um they basically
you create a file name function
they paste it or whatever and then their
content
it just writes it out so what i always
do is i just kind of
copy it um and then i'll like
you know just um i'll just paste it
underneath the
file input in this case since it's
saying download data we're going to
replace with
e v download
and then what we want to actually write
right is our model
run cool
so again we have that one of the things
i found which is a little bit
odd with the uh the download button is
that
it doesn't center right on the
actual um sidebar
um i'm not sure why uh to be honest but
you know we can click download we can
see a picture of my face
um and then what we can do is kind of
like save it as like a model
summary.csv um
we can exit out and then if we go back
there we
see our model summary
hopefully all right so we can see our
model summaries
right there obviously what we can do
with some changes is since i don't
actually like the uh
um the uh the right dot csv i'll try to
do a write underscore csv
right um so that way we it's a little
bit cleaner additionally what we might
think about
is hey maybe we want them to perhaps put
in
a file name so we can just say text
input we'll say v file name
label equals file name value goals
at and we can also add a placeholder so
we'll say
model results.csv
right um add a little comma to that
and now what we can do is basically say
um we just
we just paste uh um
paste that
um and call that a day right there
so right so model results.csv
uh we can go to was it tiger tuesday
season two
apps uh shiny reactive iris
right you know let's target pedal with
run model default is model results
um oops did i
input um
face what
um paste
oh what the hell i just thought um
paste file name maybe i can just
file name it should be
content uh
file name input maybe i can do a
dot dot csv
and then sep equals that and then maybe
i'll do a uh
final results the file name
yeah okay
let's see if that worked but again it i
don't i don't think it's really that
um big of a deal to specify
or not specify a file name
so let's run this we'll just run that
all named model results does that do
that
okay well i guess it doesn't only do one
more
try with this is that
file name i'll say model results
one last try if it doesn't work i am not
going to lose sleep over it
um season 2 apps
and reactive
okay yep so now we have model results
right there
okay and then you just save it as is off
and then i can just replace that
um i'm actually not gonna do that right
there so
yeah so you can just uh put it right
there
and right there cool
so let's actually look at the final
model i mean final dashboard just upload
a little
thing right there sorry i've kind of
gone through the same
um kind of process for
um uploading the file and you know
figuring that out but again
pretty cool we can run it right
down the summary have our model results
right there
and it's good to go so as you can see
the uh
the dashboard is pretty easy to create
especially when you're
using reactive variables um at the end
of the day you know
one of the things that's a little bit
more confusing is you know the file
inputs and file
outputs um just because you know it's
not directly uploading the file as a
data frame when we're thinking about
you know read.csv or read underscore csv
instead it's kind of passing in metadata
and then you have to pass that metadata
into your actual reading function
same thing with the output function um
it's kind of just writing it out and you
have to have a little
file name function using the download
handler but other than that
one of the things we just have to
realize is that um when we're uploading
things or using variables that are
changing
throughout the dashboard um it's always
something to consider using a reactive
variable
um and then with reactive variables you
always kind of have to use these
reactive variables as almost functions
instead but they essentially do the same
thing
secondly again with the reactive
functions um
they're pretty straightforward you just
kind of have to understand you know
event reactive
is when it's you're doing something
that'll cause something to change
and then your reactive is you know
basically the process of
on the action that's causing the change
so event reactive
is the actual event reactive is the
actual variable that's you know caused
by an invent
so i hope you liked this week's title
tuesday video
on our shiny i think again these things
are a little bit complicated but they
really
um elevate your way your shiny
development skills
and my last video on our shiny uh we're
gonna be going over basically how to
optimize the speed of dashboards so
once you have a fully working dashboard
you know running basically
uh diagnostics on you know which which
plots are taking
the most time to load how can we speed
up our dashboard using like
feather files on parallel processing and
stuff like that
so uh with that being said um i'll see
you guys next time and tidy on